hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator TV I'm Fraser Nelson I'm
joined by my colleagues philan
barnettsia for a discussion on what just
happened in Ukraine it's been quite a
week um on Monday Vladimir Putin said he
was pulling out of a deal whereby he had
guaranteed safety for Ukraine to export
grain out of Odessa and he wanted he
said guarantees um from Ukraine was
guarantees were not forthcoming and yet
Putin crawled back anyway so what was
behind it Svetlana what happened
is the main trigger for Putin to leave
their grain deal was the Drone attack on
the his backseat Fleet in sevastopol so
tell us more about that so the trigger
wasn't attacking Saturday and he's got
these ships outside the basketball which
I imagine the Russian Navy has been
there for for years because it invaded
in 2014. so they all think those ships
were pretty safe back there it was the
safest base in Crimea for Russian ships
they thought that but not anymore
because it seemed that Ukraine Got new
weapons the Navy drones that they used
as a landscape officially didn't claim
responsibility for this but Ukrainian
journalists say that the attack was made
by Ukrainian secret service right so
until then Russia didn't realize then
the Ukraine had a technology to attack
these ships when all of a sudden it's
not quite a Pearl Harbor attack but to
actually get them attacked off
Sebastopol in Russian safe territory
will make Russia feel a lot more was yes
for sure and that's why Putin was asking
Ukraine to give the guarantees for them
that Ukraine won't be selling Crimea
anymore and sevastopol he was trying to
use in the grain deal for that but the
problem is that the warships and the
ships that transport crane are two
different things and Ukraine Never Shout
the crane Corridor okay because we're
talking here about Sebastopol which is
in the East and then the grain mainly
comes via Odessa doesn't do that it's a
Ukraine exports something like 10
percent of the world's greater did so
before the war so they're quite far
apart so it's not as if
um the passage of a ships from Odessa
would have any bearing and whether or
not Ukraine would attack Russian Navy
moored and sevastable yes Ukraine has
every right to serve Russian Navy and
it's not gonna harm the grain Corridor
just put in try it to use his streak
forcing Ukraine to agree that okay
you're not gonna shut anymore just let
us explore the grain but Ukrainian
officials denied that right why did
Vision agree to the grain Corridor in
the first place because it seemed to be
quite a big of Leverage here I mean he
it's a major export for Ukraine
um so why do Putin allow Ukraine to
continue is that a cultural export
first he does to look like someone who
takes the food from the poor people
because he has not so many allies right
now and if and he needs allies in Africa
because they for now stayed natural and
putting even offer them
to sell to send the grain for free but
the problem is that Russia doesn't have
all that grain that grain would be
stolen from Ukrainian territories
currently occupied by Russia and also he
needs grain deal uh to cover his Navy
ships he thought that he thought that
but now it doesn't work anymore right so
please so he was trying
um a bit of negotiation and he wanted
Ukraine to agree to it presumably he
would have thought that perhaps
um turkey and perhaps Western allies
might have pressured Ukraine to agree to
this but what happened why was what
after he made his demand
how did the negotiations then work
surprisingly for Putin U.N turkey and
Ukraine decided just to continue with
the deal without Russia and they were
successful in doing that for three days
for the time that Russia was out of the
deal and he decided to come back thanks
to erdogan because he called Putin and
they have they had a conversation and
actually it is surprisingly because we
know erdogan as a close friend of Putin
but for him the great question is a
question of prestige and Authority in
Turkey because the president's elections
will be the next year so he was not
gonna allow that this erdogan then he
needed the green deal as well because he
gets prestige in Turkey
um not only in Turkey I would say in the
whole region in the whole region right
so then basically erdogan was asked to
choose by Putin are you going to side
with Russia or side with Ukraine here
and um erdogan went with Ukraine and
decided to keep exporting the the grain
anyway or certainly protecting the
passage of ships
yes but I wouldn't say that erdogan has
chosen a side he is trying to be between
Russia and Ukraine he wants to be a main
negotiator and I think that for now he's
the only one person that Putin listens
to right so what brought Fusion back to
the table it's pretty embarrassing to
walk out on a Monday and to have to
admit two or three days later with this
Gambit had failed I mean Fusion is a man
who doesn't like to lose face especially
against the critics he's now getting
even the Moscow
it would be more embarrassing if the
deal continued without Russia and also
if Russia still stays in the deal what
does it mean sorry for the deal to
continue without Russia
if the grant would be still exported uh
by U.N turkey and Ukraine and without
trust they will just keep doing that but
I think that he came back because he can
try to tread one more time later because
if he's in a deal he still can influence
it but if he leaves it he doesn't have
any power anymore in that all right so
this whole episode then it's just
demonstrated that that Putin has got
less leverage via the grain deal than he
might have expected
yes and
and it is not so easy as before like uh
his nuclear threats don't work as before
because I think right now the West
reacts uh much more hard
to his threats all right and also I
imagine all this was based as you were
saying earlier on this military
breakthrough but the Russian Fleet is
now vulnerable in the way that Putin
didn't think it would be so can we
expect more of these drone attracts
attacks on Russian ships yes I'm sure we
will see them in the future okay Selena
mornezia thank you very much for joining
me and you can get spitland's weekly
email about what's happening in Ukraine
by going to spectator.co.uk forward
slash Ukraine or by clicking on this
link it's free to sign up and it's the
best account you will read both English
language and Ukrainian language sources
in what's happening in the world